so you have a contract nail mm-hm and
then what happens so how long does a
rookie contract is there a year imagine
so you become a free agent after six
full services information man it's just
you know stuff I think it's interesting
because I think people probably know the
least about baseball contracts of any of
them like when somebody Ziya williamson
gets drafted yeah everyone knows how
long he has to be a pelican and what
he's gonna make and issued nobody knows
[ __ ] about us yeah we have to play six
full seasons in the big leagues so 172
days is a full season so if you don't
whatever six times 172 it's you have to
have that many days in the big leagues
to be a free agent after three years you
get arbitration okay it's like
Clevenger's in arbitration I'm next year
will be an arbitration so I'm on my last
year in my three years okay so once you
get into arbitration then what what does
that mean then it's you versus the team
and an arbitrator and your agent I don't
need to go out a nudey and you basically
argue what you're worth so the team will
sit there and tell you to your face how
bad you suck right and you'll tell them
how great you are right and then the guy
will tell you here's where we're at okay
huh interesting so after this next year
you'll be able to go in arbitration yeah
so this is a big season for you in some
ways that third season is a big season
for guys because they want to do well
that's easy yeah you have to
it's called up they call it a platform
year so this is like the worst season
you could get hurt that's what I'm a
Corey Seager you got hurt in its third
year he did primate half of what he
would have if he would have played hell
huh and but also it's interesting
because this season counts as a season
right this upcoming so I wonder if
they'll really put as much value it's
almost like well they still just go off
of lash what's a double-edged sword
right because if you do great they can
say you wouldn't sustain that and if you
do terrible they can say you were
terrible
right but arguments like well like
wouldn't sustain the shitty part either
you know but so in the end it's gonna be
the same you're gonna say there's no
Owen thing in there you're gonna say
yeah everything I mean everything counts
but yes it's business a good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watches one